تعمل وزارة الدفاع الآن على
سلسلة من الخيارات العسكرية التي توضح بالتفصيل
ما الذي ستفعله إذا
عبرت القوات الروسية الحدود
وشنّت غزوًا للدبلوماسية الأوكرانية ، من الواضح أن
العقوبات لا تزال في المقدمة والمركزية إلى
حد كبير أول شيء قد
تلجأ إليه الولايات المتحدة ولكن  البنتاغون لديه خيارات
للرئيس بايدن للنظر في
تعزيز الوجود الأمريكي في أوروبا الشرقية
لطمأنة الحلفاء هناك الذين يشعرون
بالقلق الشديد بشأن ما قد يكون بوتين على
وشك التفكير في رومانيا بولندا والدول
التي تشعر
بالتوتر الآن ، فما هو على الطاولة
يمكن للولايات المتحدة  نقل بعض القوات
والمعدات الموجودة بالفعل في أوروبا ، ويمكنه أيضًا
نقل القوات والمعدات من الولايات المتحدة
أو من خارج أوروبا إلى القارة ،
كل هذا لمنح الحلفاء
الطمأنينة وقدرة الردع
ضد روسيا ، ويحب البنتاغون دائمًا
أن يقول إنه يخطط لـ  كل شيء وهذه
حالة واحدة عندما تفعل ذلك بالفعل
فقط في حالة
باربرا ستار cnn البنتاغون